the movie begins with a teenager named
Reese in a small room full of telephones
on the walls suddenly one of them which
has a sticky note on it begins to ring
Reese picks up the phone call and hears
an automated voice which congratulates
her on getting a royal flush as she
tries to get a grasp of what's going on
other telephones also start ringing and
they all say the same thing all of a
sudden water begins to pour out of the
telephones and starts filling up the
room weird I've had this exact dream
before just then Rhys points her
attention upwards and sees a toilet
attached to the ceiling realizing that
she has to flush the toilet she begins
to climb the wall with the help of the
telephones however she is unable to
locate the toilet handle thinking that
she is going to drown if she doesn't do
anything Rhys calms down and reads the
number on the sticky note from earlier
luckily an idea strikes her mind and
with little time on her hands Rhys swims
back down and uses one of the telephones
to dial the number her plan works and
the telephone reveals a secret
compartment which contains the missing
toilet handle Reese rushes back to the
top and fixes the hand handle onto the
toilet she then flushes it which in turn
drains all the water out of the room
hence saving her life if you're doing a
telephone puzzle and you get handed a
number and you don't think to dial that
number on the telephone you you deserve
to drown however a few seconds later it
turns out that the whole experience was
only a virtual reality game Rhys takes
off her VR headset and it's revealed
that she is actually in an Esports
Center surrounded by other VR and
professional Gamers later she arrives
home and has dinner with her single
father Chris it is clear that the two
are very close as Reese lost her mother
at a very young age out of the blue the
room light begins to Flicker and short
circuits then we are shown a montage of
different electrical outputs throughout
the city which also gets destroyed in
the same fashion for some reason
everything that runs on electricity is
imploding back inside the house Chris
thinks nothing of it and assumes that
the city is going through a normal power
outage however Reese can't get a signal
and is disconnected from the outside
world unfortunately due to the ongoing
short circuits Reese's computer setup
also goes up in Flames she somehow
manages to put the fire out but is
unsuccessful in Saving her computer
later in the living room Chris lights a
lantern and tells his daughter that this
blackout was a much needed break for her
to get off of her devices true Dad Chris
the two then look at some old photos on
her iPad oh okay well and reminisce
about the times when Reese's mom was
alive soon they fall asleep on the couch
in the middle of the night Rhys hears a
strange sound coming from their
warehouse and decides to inspect it
without waking her father up she slowly
makes her way out with a lantern and
then proceeds into the warehouse there
she finds a book called radio flash
which is another term for
electromagnetic pulse or an EMP as Reese
looks around the place we get to know
that the warehouse was actually her
Grandpa Franks who left to live in the
mountains a few years back after a while
Rhys unveils a cloth blanket on the
table which turns out to have a
dismantled radio station beneath it
hoping to get some answers from Frank
she skillfully puts together the parts
and connects the radio successfully she
then turns on the device and calls her
grandfather who replies a few seconds
later it turns out that Frank is also
very concerned about the power outage
which he calls apocalyptic according to
him almost the entire western part of
the United States has been affected by
this mysterious outage he guesses that
it might have something to do with an
electromagnetic pulse attack Frank then
asks for Chris but learns that he is
already asleep so he instructs Rhys to
summon him to the radio the next morning
as they have very little time laughed he
wants the father-daughter Duo to
immediately leave their home and join
him in the mountains as he has plenty of
supplies stocked there before ending the
call Frank guides Reese to a map and a
mobile radio which will Aid them in
their Journey the radio however will
only work once they are in a 5-mile
radius from Frank all of this indicates
that he had already prepared for this
event way back in the past resobliges
and the very next morning she informs
her father of the situation at first
Chris refuses to go to Frank's Place
claiming that he is a lunatic but when
his daughter keeps on insisting he
decides to at least call The Old Man
shortly after the two head to the
warehouse and restarts the radio
transmission after she leaves Chris and
Frank begin their conversation at first
the old man proceeds to explain the
truth behind the power outage he reveals
that everything that is happening is the
effect of an EMP which will soon cause
chaos Bedlam in every part of the states
he also claims that supplies and tools
will become scarce in just three days
time so living in the mountains with him
is the only safe option hearing all this
Chris is finally convinced and he makes
up his mind to leave immediately after a
while he along with Rhys start packing
their belongings while the situation
outside begins to worsen police and
civilians are at each other's necks
because of the prolonged power outage no
one knows what is happening or when it
will end popo how am I supposed to
figure out how I feel about this one
looks like a tick tock out of it you
know meanwhile Chris and Rhys hop in
their car and start their Journey on
their way they stop by the only open
supermarket in the area to get some
supplies however when they witness
extensive violence among people for
common supplies like water and food they
quickly Retreat as they leave the place
we are shown that thousands of other
people are also trying to get out of the
city in the next scene the
father-daughter Duo is forced to stop on
a bridge because of an accident blocking
the highway a lady has seemingly lost
her life and Rhys Witnesses this a few
hours later the tension in the bridge
reaches a boiling point and an impatient
man Rams his vehicle into another this
opens up the road so Chris and Rhys
quickly rushed back to their vehicle and
continue their Journey later that night
Reese wakes up and finds out that they
have missed the intersection and are
going the wrong way this distracts Chris
and he momentarily takes his eyes off
the road the Split Second turns out to
be costly as he loses control of the car
and crashes it into the nearby Woods boy
what I would do for a movie like this
that skips the cliches you know what I'm
saying the next morning Reese is woken
up by her father who is relieved to see
her without any injuries however Chris
seems to have hit his head and is
bleeding a little the two then decide to
follow a nearby River to get to Frank's
location as it will save them a
considerable amount of time elsewhere
Frank starts to get concerned about the
duo as they were already supposed to
have arrived by the morning in the
meantime Chris is having a hard time
walking so Reece suggests they rest for
a while they stop by a nearby waterfall
and fill up on water there Reese finds
out that her father has a severe bruise
on his back and also has a deep cut on
his arm she immediately starts treating
his wounds despite Chris stating that he
will be fine after a while they resumed
their Journey but Chris becomes weaker
by the minute and eventually collapses
before losing Consciousness he instructs
his daughter to call for help hence
without wasting any time Rhys runs
through the forest where she fortunately
finds a barn and a farmer named Glenn
seeing the distressed girl he quickly
Springs into action and brings Chris
back home in his car unfortunately
despite every medical intervention Chris
doesn't regain Consciousness and
eventually stops breathing Reese's
devastated and heartbroken as her only
parent is now gone the same night she
and Glenn bury him in the field and they
pay their respects the next day Glenn
decides to help Reese get to her
grandfather's place and soon they begin
their journey in his trailer on the
other hand Frank is tired of waiting so
he decides to go look for Chris and Rhys
himself a few hours later he comes
across their crash site and a piece of
bloody cloth on the floor beside the car
Frank then follows the road and finds
the farm where Reese was previously
located he goes to see if anyone is home
but surprise surprisingly sees Blood on
the sofa suspicious he breaks in and
starts inspecting the place after not
finding anything he takes a good look at
Glenn's photo and then heads off outside
he notices the recently used shovel
Chris's clothes and also his burial site
Frank now knows that Chris is dead but
he doesn't have time to grieve as Rhys
his granddaughter is still missing
elsewhere along the way Glenn notices a
man on the side of the road asking for
help for safety precautions he tells
Rhys to quickly go to the back of the
trailer fearing the man might be up to
something Shady Glenn's worst fear comes
true as the man pulls a gun on him and
shoots him dead the unnamed man then
gets into the trailer and drives off
with a traumatized race still inside of
it after a while he stops by a car
repair shop and sneaks in to steal
gasoline from a truck all of a sudden
the man gets shot by a hunter and Reese
uses this opportunity to flee plot twist
Reese's in VR again and she's playing
fortnite however not long after she gets
caught by the same Hunter who puts a bag
over her head when she finally opens her
eyes she is greeted by a strange old
woman claims that Rhys trespassed on her
property so now she will have to pay for
it meanwhile Frank finds Glenn's dead
body and identifies him as the man from
the photo this makes him worry even more
for Reese and so he continues to search
for answers on the other hand during
dinner the old woman introduces Rhys to
her family her son is Billy the hunter
from earlier and Quinn her shy and
troubled grandson it turns out Billy
always beats and humiliates his son for
no apparent reason after the
introductions Reese explains the course
of events on how she got here she also
asserts that she cannot stay any longer
as she has to get to her grandpa's as
soon as possible however the old woman
feels no sympathy and doesn't let her
leave instead she forces her to stay in
the attic for the night left with no
choice Rhys heads to the attic but has
no intention of spending the night in an
attempt to escape she sneaks to the main
door while everyone is asleep she then
opens the lock but the old woman hears
it and immediately sends Billy after her
an intense Chase ensues but the teenager
is eventually caught and brought back
home by the menacing Hunter when Reese
comes to her senses she finds herself
tied up inside a bag which is hanging on
a tree just then a large bear approaches
her and tries to tear open the bag it
appears as if the teenager is about to
bite the dust but Billy arrives there in
the neck of time and shoots the bear
down it turns out Reese was simply used
as bait to lure the giant Beast after
the close encounter she is taken to a
small store room where Billy leaves her
for a week but one day he takes her out
and the old woman tries to convince her
to stay and to become a partner to one
of her sons however Rhys responds that
she would rather be inside the storeroom
than be with those Maniacs her wish is
fulfilled as the enraged woman orders
Reese to be thrown back into the
storeroom this time both her hands and
feet are tied desperate to escape Rhys
manages to cut open the Rope on her
hands and finally unties herself however
she cannot figure out a plan to escape
just then she notices Quinn peeking at
her and thinks of a plan Rhys knows that
he feels sympathy for her so she decides
to exploit this weakness of his she
starts coercing him for help and
surprisingly Quinn who is fed up with
the constant abuse from both his grandma
and his father agrees not to mention
he's simping just a little bit he lets
her out of the storeroom and without
further Ado they escape the compound
together and run through the night the
next morning Billy finds out that both
of them have fled and immediately begins
his search he follows their footsteps
and broken branches slowly but surely
catching up to them on the other hand
Quinn and Reese bond together and eat
berries as they have run far off from
the compound a few moments later they
reach a cliff where Quinn nearly falls
to his death but Reese manages to save
him they then come across a log which
acts as a bridge and they slowly make
their way across it all of a sudden
Billy spots them from afar and takes a
shot which luckily doesn't connect
terrified the teenagers start running
and they come across a Shallow Lake
realizing that they cannot outrun Billy
they submerge themselves in the water to
hide after the hunter crosses them
recent Quinn get out from the lake and
flee in the opposite direction however
as Billy is a seasoned Hunter he notices
them from behind his back and Tails them
again eventually he catches up to the
them so Quinn decides to take him on
while Rhys hides behind a rock as the
two tussle Billy's gun Falls in front of
Reese but she hesitates to use it
however when she realizes that Quinn
will be beaten to death if she doesn't
take any action Reese gains the
confidence to pick up the gun she aims
for Billy and finishes him off with one
clean shot but surprisingly it is
revealed that it was actually her
Grandpa Frank who fired the gun and
saved the teenagers he arrived at the
place after hearing the gunshots
relieved Reese runs to her Grandpa and
hugs him tightly while tearing up the
scene cuts to sometime in the future
where both Rhys and Quinn live with
Frank and do activities as a family the
world is still suffering from the after
effects of the EMP but here in the
mountains everything that is required to
survive is available in abundance the
movie ends as Quinn opens Reese's laptop
and notices several messages from her
friends indicating that the power outage
problem is finally coming to an end
finally we can return to our postmodern
hellscape and forget about everything
we've learned
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching